JASON SILVA: You
know, I'm somebody
that's a real big hoarder
of quotes and ideas.
Whenever I stumble
upon something
that's exquisitely
well written, I
long to capture it, to
clothe it, to transcribe it,
to basically record it.
There is a manic
desire to capture
the reverberation of something
magnificent, of something
beautiful.
And so there's all
these lines that I
have in my head that seem to
apply to almost every moment
of contemplative exactitude.
One of them, of course, is,
I look upon this horizon
and I think to myself, and
all the clocks in the city
began to whir and chime.
Oh, let not time deceive you.
You cannot conquer time.
In headaches and in worries
vaguely life leaks away.
And time will have its
fancy tomorrow, or today.
So that's kind of
depressing, right?
That's about dread.
That's about time
passing, no matter what.
But then there's other lines.
Other lines that inspire me.
One of those lines, for example,
could be something like,
to see the world
in a grain of sand,
and the heaven in a wild flower.
Hold infinity in the
palm of your hand,
hold eternity in an hour.
All of a sudden,
everything is radiant.
Everything is resplendent.
Everything is
beautiful, again, right?
It's like when
Henry Miller says,
even a blade of grass when
given proper attention becomes
a magnificent thing in itself.
So what does that tell us?
That something as mundane
as grass can be exquisite.
That something as
dull as the every day
can become magnificent,
resplendent, miraculous,
divine.
Only if we're able to tweak
our perceptions, to shift
our perception,
through the arresting
and modulation of attention.
That's why cinema, that's
why poetry, that's why art,
arrests the body
mind and thrusts it
towards the numinous.
And that's such an
important thing.
And all of a sudden we
become like Dylan Thomas.
And we feel inspired.
And we say, I love
this moment so much.
I will not go gently
into that goodnight.
I will rage, rage against
the dying of the light.
I will practice random kindness
and senseless acts of beauty.
Because minds are like
parachutes and they only
function when open.
And Timothy Leary was right.
In order to use
your head, you've
got to go out of your mind.
It's amazing how the self
is mediated by the ideas
that it is exposed to.
My very personality,
my very quest,
is shaped and authored
by the bumper stickers,
by the words of wisdom, that
I stumble upon along the way.
Think about that for a minute.
There's a documentary
I saw once,
it was called "In Search
of the Miraculous."
And isn't that the search?
I mean isn't the search for
the divine, for the miraculous,
for the inconceivably sublime,
what life is all about?
Isn't that what Joseph Campbell
talked about when he talked
about the hero's journey?
And apotheosis, and rebirth,
and resurrection, right?
Holy moments, the mysterium
tremendum et fascinosum.
And again, it all comes down
to controlling and mediating
our attention.
Darwin said it best.
Attention, if sudden
and close graduates
into surprise, and this
into astonishment, and this
into stupefied amazement.
So if you are a wonder junkie,
if you believe as Carl Sagan
did that understanding
is a kind of ecstasy.
If you are hungry
for the sublime,
learn to control your attention.
Learn to control your
mind, your thoughts.
Because your creative
and linguistic choices,
the very words you use
to map your reality,
feed back into your reality.
You are the painting.
You are the paintbrush.
s You are the canvas.
You are the question.
You are the answer to the
question you are looking for.
You are, also my
friends, the question.
You are everything.
We are everything.
We are sentient.
We are consciousness.
The most sublime, miraculous
thing in the universe.
So you'd better be having a good
time and authoring your fate.
Turn your life into a living,
breathing, work of art,
because anything less
would be a tragedy.